Transcriber: Melisa Açar
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Merhabalar.
Valla persona  konusu biraz
çalışmadığım yerden geldi bana ama
mümkün olduğunca toparlamaya çalışacağım.
Bir soruyla başlayalım.
Hayatında hiç fotoğraf çekmemiş
olan var mı ?
Yok değil mi?
Peki çekmiş olduğu fotoğrafı
elinde tutmuş olan var mı?
Fena değil.
Hatta en iyilerinden biri
konuştuğum yerlerde.
Peki çekmiş olduğu fotoğrafı
kopyalamış olan var mı ?
Ben genelde hiç bu kadar görmedim. Süper.
Evet, ben buraya aslında
fotoğrafçı olarak geldim ama
hayata bilgisayar
mühendisi olarak başladım
Ve gerçekten de hayata başlangıcım
Bunun gibi bilgisayarların içinde oldu.
Babamın mesleğinden dolayı
daha böyle 2-3 yaşında çocukken
bu gördüğünüz bilgisayarların
içinde koşturuyordum, oynuyordum.
Oradaki abileri izliyordum ve
bana hayatımın ilk bilgisayar
oyununu oynattılar.
Dikkat ederseniz burada bu
bilgisayarın monitörü dahi yok.
Burada bir daktilo-printer
karışımı bir şey var.
Bütün iletişimi oradan kuruyoruz.
Oynadığım oyun da golf oyunuydu.
Bilgisayar bir tane “u”
bir tane de “o” çiziyor.
“o” top, “u” delik.
Ve sizden aradaki mesafeyi
tahmin etmenizi bekliyor.
Diyoruz ki 10 santim.
Klavyeden yazıyorsunuz.
“o” yu 10 santim sanal alıyor
ikinci satırda.
Bir daha tahmin ediyoruz 3 santim
Biraz daha yaklaştırıyor.
Bundan sonrası kolay.
Bir diyoruz, kendi gidiyor.
Bu benim 50 yıl önce oynadığım ilk ilk
ilk bilgisayar oyunum.
Ve dediğim gibi o kocaman,
oda gibi bilgisayarın içindeydim.
Ve o günden sonra
hep ben bilgisayarlarla beraberdim.
Ortaokulda ilk kendime ait
bilgisayarıma sahip oldum
ve o anda benim için dünya değişti.
İlk programımı yaptım ve dedim ki ben
artık tamamen hayatım boyunca
bilgisayar işiyle uğraşacağım.
Ve...
lise 1 veya lise 2′de ilk bilgisayar
şirketimi kurdum.
Üç tane arkadaşımla beraber.
Bu da kartvizitimiz.
O zamanlarda IBM vardı hala
var da kimse hatırlamaz belki
Onun logosunun çakmasını yapmıştık.
Matbaa yanlış anlamış, “m”yi
“w” diye basmış.
Hatta Kerim, Burak, “m” gitti 3 ortak
yenisini de bastıracak paramız yoktu.
Bu kartvizit böyle kaldı ve
biz daha lise 2′de iken
bir fabrikanın üretim
kontrol programını yazdık.
O üç tane ufak çocuk.
Ve yaklaşık 10 -12 yıl o fabrikanın
üretimini bizim o yazdığımız program
yaptı, idare etti.
Böyle geçti ve hep teknolojinin
en en en önünde gittim.
Yani ne yenilik varsa, işte
yeni bilgisayar çıktıysa
en hızlısı, en yenisi
devamlı bütün günüm program
yazarak geçiyor.
İşte bildiğimiz bütün aletlerin ilk
çıkanını işte, işte iphone’ın ilki
kindle’ın ilki,
şunun ilki bunun ilki
Kullanılan bütün yazılımların ilk
versionlarından itibaren böyle bir
hayat geçti.
Hatta şu anda çok popüler
olan bu vr gözlükler.
Ben bunları 2000 yılında
ilk deneysel bir aşamadayken
Amerika’da bir üniversitede denedim.
Böyle bir hayat geçerken bir de
benim hobim fotoğrafçılık
fotoğraf da dijital oluverdi bir anda.
Ve hemen bir dijital
fotoğraf makinesi tabi
Bu herhalde 2000 yılında
bir megapiksellik müthiş bir makineydi
Ve ondan sonra
fotoğraf, fotoğraf, fotoğraf.
Her yıl yeni makine, yeni programlar,
yeni yazılımlar.
Derken bir gün bir baktım benim oğlum
4-5 yaşında 30bin tane fotoğrafını çekmiş.
Ama bir tane doğru dürüst elimde
tutabileceğim  fotoğrafı yok.
Dedim burada bir terslik var.
Yavaş yavaş bunları basmaya başladım.
İşte o printer mı iyi bu kağıt mı iyi
derken bir şeyi fark ettim.
Bir fotoğrafı kaç kişi çekiyor?
İyi güzel, ben o düğmeye basıyorum da
sonradan o kağıdı print ediyorum da
o kadar iyi bir printer olmasa
ben o sonucu alamayacağım.
o kadar iyi bir kağıt o kadar
kaliteli mürekkepler olmasa
ben yine o sonucu alamayacağım.
Ve bilmem kaç megapiksellik,
işte hangi rengi ekleyince şöyle olan
zavazingo bir makinem olmasa
o kadar iyi bir sonuç alamayacağım.
Bilgisayarda da photoshop
da şurda burda işliyoruz
o programları yapanlar olmasa
yine ben o sonucu alamayacağım.
Burada benim dışımda o kadar çok insanın
burda etkisi var ki yavaş yavaş beni
tekrar analog tekniklere
döndürmeye başladı.
Onu denerken, bunu denerken
benim şu andaki fotoğraf bu.
Bu zaman zaman internette dolaşır.
Dünyanın ilk fotoğraf makinesi
diye görmüşsünüzdür.
O 2-3 ayda bir gelir bana.
Şu. Buna benziyor değil mi?
Bu ilk fotoğraf makinesi falan
değil hani önümüze çıkarsa.
Yani şu anda Google’da ilk fotoğraf
makinesi dediğiniz zaman bile
karşınıza ilk bu çıkıyor.
Tamamen bir palavra. İlk fotoğraf
makinesi böyle minicik bir kutu.
Eğer merak ediyorsanız, aynen bu konuya
girersek bu konu çok uzar.
Gelelim bizim konuya.
Bizim makine bu.
Bununla nasıl fotoğraf çekeceksiniz?
Bunun içine ışığa hassas
bir şey koymak lazım.
Benim kullandığım cam.
Ve camı kimyasal işlemlerle
filme çeviriyorum.
Filme dönüştürüyorum.
Burada döktüğüm sıvı benim kendi
hazırladığım sıvı bir film.
Ve bunu camın üstüne döktüğüm zaman
cam ışığa hassas hale geliyor.
Bu cam o gördüğünüz kocaman makinenin
içine giriyor, fotoğraf çekiliyor ve
sonra tekrar
bir takım kimyasal prosedürlerden geçiyor.
Bu da böyle çok kısaca çok
uzun 10-15 dakikalık bir süreç ama
son anını en azından bir fotoğrafın
oluşumunu görebilmek açısından şey yaptı.
Görüyor musunuz yavaş yavaş
çıkıyor görüntü ama negatif şu anda.
Başka bir kimyasala giriyor.
Tişört de aynıymış .
Ve camın üstünde böyle
bir görüntü çıkıyor.
Bu tek, kopyalanamayan bir fotoğraf.
Biraz daha yakından gösterilmiş
keşke bunun gerçeğini görebilseniz.
Çünkü bir obje.
Bunun üzerinde gördüğünüz görüntü
Yüzde yüz saf gümüş.
Ve bu lavanta kokuyor.
Çünkü üstüne lavanta yağı ile
hazırlanmış bir vernik sürülüyor.
Başka bir teknikle bunu yapsaydım o zaman
asfalt kokacaktı ki onu da yapıyorum.
Çünkü o zamanda vernik yerine
asfalt sürmek gerekiyor gibi.
Bu işin içine girdiğim zaman
yüzlerce farklı teknik,
yüzlerce baskı metodu.
Bir şeyin içinde buldum kendimi.
Burada bir pozitif yapıyoruz.
Yani bu bir camın üzerinde kopyalanamayan
yani tek pozitif bir görüntü.
Ama istersek de yine aynı camın
üzerinde negatif yapabiliyoruz.
Geçen gün bir üniversiteden fotoğraf
kulübü geldi benim atölyeye.
Ben anlatıyorum işte pozitif
negatif falan “ya hocam” dedi
“Kusura bakmayın siz diyorsun da pozitif
ne demek, negatif ne demek” dedi.
Dedim herhalde artık yeni
jenerasyon için pozitif-negatif
bir tek pcr testinin sonucu.
Bilmiyorum anlatmaya gerek
var mı ama bu şeffaf bir cam.
Bu siyah gördüğünüz yerlerden
ışık geçmiyor, az geçiyor.
Beyaz gördüğünüz yerler şeffaf.
Buradan ışık geçiyor.
Bu negatifi bir kağıdın üzerine koyup yine
ışığa hassas bir kağıdın üzerine koyup
ışığa maruz bıraktığınız zaman
kullandığınız tekniğe göre bunun pozitif
görüntüsünü elde edebiliyorsunuz.
Ama tabii böyle de bir kağıt lazım.
Böyle bir kağıt yok.
Hani ne dedik, burada her şeyi
kendimiz yapmaya çalışıyoruz ya
Filmi yaptık
Kağıdı da aslında yapabilirim.
Ama kağıt, düz kağıdı
ben satın alıyorum.
Işığa hassas, kullanacağım tekniğe göre
ışığa hassas hale getirmeye çalışıyorum.
O process de nasıl başlıyor
biliyor musunuz?
Yumurtayı beyazıyla sarısını ayırarak
başlıyor kağıdı hazırlamak.
Birtakım kimyasallar giriyor içine.
Ve tarihi reçetelere göre bu işi
yapmaya kalktığınız zaman 6 ay sürüyor.
Kağıdın iyi kalitede hazır olabilmesi.
Tabi o kadar bekleyemiyoruz.
Daha çabuk yapıyoruz
ve pandemi sırasında
bizim de psikolojimiz bozuldu artık
Bach eşliğinde falan
çalışmıyoruz, böyle çalışıyoruz.
Ondan sonra işte akıyı meneng
haline getirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Mutfak gibi çalışıyoruz ve daha sonra
işte bunlar kağıdın üzerine kaplanıyor.
Bir takım başka kimyasal
işlemlerden geçtiği zaman
Böyle bir görüntü elde ediyoruz.
Kağıdın üstü yumurta akı kaplı .
İçinde gümüş molekülleri var.
Bu da bir obje.
Bunu da bazen bal mumu ile kaplıyoruz.
O zaman bal mumu kokuyor.
Ve bu tarihi tekniklere girdiğimiz
zaman sonsuz.
Yani daha benim yaptıklarım,
yapamadıklarım o kadar var ki.
Birkaç örnek burada şey yaptım.
Bu ilk tekniklerden biri.
Bu da ilk fotoğraf tekniklerinden
birini keşfeden Daguerre.
Bu gördüğünüz fotoğraf bir gümüş plaka
ve gümüş plakanın üstünde
varla yok arası bir imaj var.
Bunu elde tutmak bambaşka bir şey.
Böyle görmek tabii olmuyor.
Bu kağıdın üstünde
platin molekülleri var.
Görüntüyü size ortaya çıkartan platin.
Burada da hem platin hem paladyum
karışımı yine kağıdın üstünde.
Bu teknikte de görüntüyü
oluşturan mürekkep.
Siyah mürekkep kullanırsanız siyah,
kahverengi mürekkep
renkli mürekkep, istediğiniz
gibi resim yapar gibi bir ortam var.
Burada da görüntüyü
oluşturan yağlı boya.
Kağıdın üzerinde önce fotografik birtakım
işlemlerle bir rölyef hazırlayıp üstünü
yağlı boyayla boyadığınız zaman böyle
bir görüntü elde edebiliyorsunuz.
Burada da görüntü altın.
Dediğim gibi yani bunların
her biri bir obje.
Elde tutmak, koklamak ve değişik ışık.
Düzgün ışıkta baktığınız zaman
hepsi birer mucize.
Derken.
Ben işte
bu kadar dijitalleşmiş
bu kadar her şeyi artık
bilgisayarların, yapay akılların yaptığı,
her şeyi onlara bıraktığımız
bir dünyada mümkün olduğunca
bir insan olarak işte ellerimle
kendi yeteneğim ile neler yapabilirim
bu alanda mücadele vermeye çalışıyorum.
Ama zaman zaman da şunu düşünüyorum
şimdi tekrar bizim golf oyununa döndük.
Bugün golf böyle oynanıyor.
Aradan 50 yıl geçti.
İşte sanal gerçeklik, gözlük her şey.
Ve şunu düşünmeye başladım
1972 - 2022.
Buradan buraya gelmek
sadece bir insanın ömründe
daha Allah’a şükür ömrüm de devam ediyor.
Daha neler göreceğim.
Bir ömürde bu kadar büyük
bir değişim oldu.
Hele hele bilgisayar dediğimiz şey yine
bir ömürde buradan geldi buraya.
Peki o zaman insan düşünüyor
veya beraber düşünelim.
Elli yılda bu olduysa önümüzdeki yüz, yüz
elli ve iki yüz yılda neler olabilir?
İşte o beni çıldırtıyor.
Ve son zamanlarda simülasyon teorisi
ile ilgili bir kitap okudum.
Bilmiyorum okuyanlar var mı
veya ilgilenenler var mı.
Yani belki de bundan 1000 yıl sonra
bugün içinde yaşadığımız gerçeklikte bir
bilgisayar sistemi niye olamasın?
Yani hep bunu diyorum.
Bu 50 yıl.
İlerideki bin yılda
belki de gerçekten
bu kadar gerçek bir bilgisayar sistemi ve
bunun içinde yaşayan insanlar olabilecek.
Yani belki de ben
kendi kendime anlatıyorum.
Ben bu dijitallerin içinde
analog yaşıyorum derken
belki de ben de hakikaten bir
simülasyonun içinde yaşıyorum
onu da bilemiyorum.
Onun için de kafam çok karışık.
Birazcık da sizin kafanızı
karıştırmak istedim.
Eğer vakit varsa çok kısa bir de
en son tamamlayabildiğim fotoğraf
projesinden bahsedeyim.
Bakalım gelebilecek miyiz?
Şu fotoğraflara bir bakalım.
Bunlar da az önce gördüğünüz tekniklerle
camın üstüne yapılmış fotoğraflar.
Dikkatle baktıysanız bir şey
fark ettiniz mi? Hepsinin ortak tarafını?
Niye geçmiyor? Takıldı.
Bunların hepsi aynı kişi.
Hah şöyle.
Hepsi aynı kişi.
İki yıllık bir projeydi.
Burada şuna bakmaya çalıştık.
Tam kafamızda bunlarla meşgulken
biz bir kendimizde bir kişilik,
işte burada bahsettiğimiz persona.
Acaba onun altında, gerisinde başka
personalar da var mı ?
Geçmiş hayatlardan taşıdığımız bazı
kimliklerimiz var mı hala içimizde?
Belki geçmiş oyunlarda, simülasyonlarda
takındığımız roller var mı ?
Yoksa hepimiz aynı bir büyük bir bütünün
ufak ufak parçaları mıyız?
Burada da birazcık bunu
sorgulamaya çalıştık.
Umarım toparlayabilmişimdir.
Çok teşekkür ederim.